hast du eigentlich gewusst dass der ceo von
google Sundar Pichai in indien geboren wurde
ebenso wieder überaus erfolgreiche sie auch von
microsoft satya nadella und jetzt ratet mal wo
der ceo von adobe geboren wurde Santanu Narayen
wurde ebenfalls in indien geworden tja es sieht
ganz so aus als würde in die iren das ganze liegt
überlegt übernehmen ja eigentlich die software
industrie weltweit was meisten sie zum beispiel
die größten dienstleistungsunternehmen der welt
nein accenture ist es nicht und dies ist schon gar
nicht es ist die cs ein indisches unternehmen so
und jetzt fragst du dich wahrscheinlich indien ist
das nicht auch ein entwicklungsland und das ist in
der tat war zwei drittel der inder leben unterhalb
der armutsgrenze 73 millionen leben in extremer
armut 78 millionen leben in slums nur circa acht
prozent der inder haben einen hochschulabschluss
verglichen mit 34 prozent der us-bürger und jetzt
hatte ich mal fest 20 prozent der inder sind sogar
analphabeten denn in denen das sind eigentlich
zwei länder in einem das arme indien und tag in dr
und wenn dieses tech indien eigenständiges land
wäre wäre es sowohl haben sie deutschland es hat
ein bruttoinlandsprodukt von 177 milliarden us
dollar das sind 44 1000 dollar pro kopf es würde
vier millionen arbeitnehmer beschäftigen denn
allein die vier großen indischen it-unternehmen
tcs infosys und wipro beschäftigen über eine
million hoch qualifizierte mitarbeiter und
falls du wie ich auch interaktive arbeitest
hast du sicher schon mal mit anderen zu tun
gehabt denn fast jedes größere unternehmen hat
schon mal nach indien outsourced der indische
software entwickler werden weltweit geschätzt
viele von ihnen landen im silicon valley und
in spitzenpositionen wie eben erwähnten
sie ob es aber trotzdem hinterlässt das
alles viele offene fragen denn offensichtlich
haben wir einen großen widerspruch auf der
einen seite ist indien ein land mit riesigen
bildungsprobleme und auf der anderen seite
ist es der zweitgrößte software portal der
welt nun heute werden wir diesen widerspruch
für euch natürlich auflösen und das wie
immer ein blick zurück in die geschichte
die richtige idee aber der falsche weg hier
leute also sie in indien mit mahatma gandhi
aber gandhi wurde 1948 ermordet bevor in
denen seine erste verfassung verabschiedet
denn tatsächlich ist die entscheidende figur in
unserer geschichte nicht mehr hatten und an diesen
seines zeichens erster premierminister indiens
von 1947 bis 64 unter seiner regierung wurde die
erste verfassung eines eigenständigen unabhängigen
indiens verabschiedet aber ernährung hatte darüber
hinaus noch eine ganz andere vision er wollte
die ehemalige britische kronkolonie zu einem
pionier in der computer herstellung machen aber
wie um alles in der welt sollte indien das damals
schaffen ohne ehrung dachte natürlich er hätte die
lösung dafür gefunden anstatt sich am britischen
modells orientieren ließ sich nero von stalin
inspirieren so führte in der viele kommunistische
elemente wie zb fünf jahres planung und ein
importverbot für güter um die lokale industrie
zu fördern mit hilfe dieser plan soll schafft
und formationen entstanden nationale gedanken die
stark vom staat gefördert wurden der wichtigste
davon ist ein mischkonzern tata in europa vor
allem für billige autos bekannt ist aber dann
macht noch viel viel mehr er gründete die
erste fluggesellschaft indiens und auch die erste
indische computers theater computer services oder
die cs parallel dazu investierte die regierung
stark in bildung in den 160 jahren wurden viele
technische universitäten die sogenannte waste
technology oder it gegründet in diesem sollten
viele juden der darauf vorbereitet werden in der
aufstrebenden computerindustrie zu arbeiten das
problem dabei es gab keine unternehmen für diese
arbeiten konnten denn abgesehen von katar gab es
so gut wie keine anderen technologieunternehmen
der grund ein unglaublich schlechtes klima für
gründer denn dadurch dass sich loki importe
verbunden wurden gab es ja keine komponenten
auf internationalen qualitäts niveau auf die diese
neuen kleinen firmen hätten zurückgreifen können
und so gab es in den siebziger jahren in ganz
indien nur etwa 150 computer und diese wurden alle
von ibm importiert denn ibm das irgendwie gelungen
und die strengen vorschriften des indischen
marktes zu umgehen alles in allem war das also
für nero ein riesiger bauchplatscher so jetzt
kommt aber unsere zweite protagonist in unserer
geschichte dann die sieger in den sechziger und
siebzigerjahren indische premierminister indira
gandhi ist übrigens wieder die tochter von mahatma
gandhi jedoch irgendwie mit ihm verwandt sie ist
vielmehr die tochter des ersten premierminister
und siehe da die kluge frau erkannte was
die einzigen computer in indien von einer
ausländischen firma importiert wurden dummerweise
folkmusik habe einfach nur weiter der logik ihres
vaters sie dachte einfach dass die vorschriften
nicht streng genug seien und so verabschiedete
sie 1973 den foreign exchange act welcher die
einfuhr von computern fast unmöglich machte dies
gab dem markt den letzten schlag und sogar ibm zog
sich noch im selben jahr aus dem indischen markt
zurück tja und wenn du jetzt vielleicht denkst
das wären gute nachrichten für die indischen
hersteller die diese lücke dann irgendwie fühlen
könnten tja falsch gedacht das gegenteil war der
fall denn damit verschwanden computer praktisch
völlig aus und indien konnte auch keine computer
exportieren den lieferbeschränkungen führen
fast immer zu gegenreaktionen der anderen
länder und deswegen kaufte die welt lieber
amerikanische und japanische bringt also
wie schaffte indien damit doch noch die kurve
nun das ganze spiel änderte sich nutzen kann
lehren aus den eigenen szene nur 82 war indien
der gastgeber der asien spiele das ist so etwas
wie die olympischen spiele aber nur für asien
und der organisationschef dieser spiele war
niemand anderes als dann die diesmal er
war da so von im iran die ja scheinbar
ist die ganze indischen politik so was wie
ein familienunternehmen aber dieser gandhi
war ganz anders als seine mutter denn er verstand
wirklich etwas von technik und er wollte computer
für die asienspiele einsetzen aber als er dann
zur tat schreiten wollte merkte er dass es im
ganzen land eigentlich fast keine computer
gibt aber aktiv gab nicht auf für ihn war
es eher so etwas wie ein weckruf 1984 wurde seine
mutter von zwei leibwächtern ermordet und relativ
wurde wie es in einem familienunternehmen wird
also in indien braucht ist premierminister und
schon zusammen amtsantritt verzückt er eine 180
grad wende der indischen industrie politik erhob
viele zölle und importverbote auf youtube nun
vollkommen zollfrei importiert werden solange
sie der entwicklung falls verdienten aber da kann
die so technisch versierte war musste er das ist
eigentlich zu spät war um indien eine führende
rolle in der herstellung zu sichern deswegen
fasste er schon die nächste revolution ins auge
software und er lag damit natürlich goldrichtig
bist du es lateinamerikanischen
software-entwicklern sechsstellige
gehälter zahlen zu müssen dann bist du goldrichtig
bei technik im jahr universitäten auf dem neuesten
stand der technik braucht qualifizierte und
hochgradig motivierte mitarbeiter und was meinst
du was nicht das alles kostet in einer neuen ein
indischer programmierer künftig nicht nur 10 20
oder 30 prozent günstiger als ein amerikanischer
in einer kostet dich doch nicht bald die hälfte
mein gott du bist das was ich dir sage nicht
fassen können denn du bekommst darf alles
top ausgebildete experten die fliesen englisch
sprechen ist alles land an mathe asse das alles
war ein unglaubliches fünftel eines amerikanischen
programmierers 120000 deiner bisherigen lohnkosten
und mit den 80-prozentigen mit teck india sparst
du expandieren oder eine große party schmeißen
ach was du kannst expandiert wird jeden tag eine
riesen party schmeißen denn das ist nur möglich
bei tee und das beste ist muss noch nicht mal
mit einer lokalen firma zusammenarbeiten oder
dein büro und ähnlichen einrichten denn wir haben
keine kosten und mühen gescheut um wirklich alles
so bequem wie möglich zu machen wir haben sogar
eines satelliten gebaut damit du von deinem
nordamerikanischen hauptsitz einfach deine mission
außen kommunizieren kannst in echtzeit profitiere
also auch du von der teck in die jahre von uns
nur sparen bares geld komplett anders gerade getan
texas instruments hatte auch schon getan sogar
die em hat ein großes comeback auf unserem markt
erlebt denn jeder sparte in der verpasst nicht
diese riesen gelegenheit so musste jeder kosten
zu sparen wie nie zuvor hof jetzt sofort an 0 800
tech in der prävention nur steuerleichterungen
spanischen oder englischen steuerberater und
plötzlich schoss die zahl der computer von 1000
im jahr 1968 auf über 80.000 im jahr 1990 hoch
und dann irgendwie theater computer services oder
- dann kommt das wurden 2000 partner für große us
firmen wie hewlett packard und die regierung war
mehr als glücklich dennoch früher als westliche
nationen lassen der in die pionierarbeit bei
elektronischen wahlautomaten computergestützten
bankgeschäften und sogar digitalen bahnfahrkarten
und die ganze welt betrachtete indien
als hauptanlaufpunkt für ihre it aus
die computer revolution kommt nach indien
auf ihre eigene weise etwa zur gleichen zeit
wurde die national association of software
service companies nachts kommen begründet
sie wurde die führende lobbyorganisation für die
liberalisierung der indischen fondsindustrie aber
ging das wirklich alles so einfach führte diese
marktliberalisierung ganz automatisch dazu dass
indien von internationalen unternehmen überrannt
wurde nun nicht ganz denn es gab hier einen
kleinen trick das wirklich noch eine indischen
universitäten und an all die absolventen die
in indien keine arbeit fanden weil keine kleineren
gründe unternehmen gründen konnten nun viele davon
gingen ins silicon valley und ihr einfluss in
den us firmen stieg und stieg jedes jahr und dies
hat der rückkopplungseffekte zurück in die front
diese aussage in der halterung eine gesetzgebung
zu schaffen die genau auf die bedürfnisse der
unternehmen zugeschnitten ist außerdem überzeugt
dass sie ihre us-manager sich von indien statt für
andere länder zu entscheiden wenn es nicht aus ein
gutes beispiel dafür wie viel praxisorientierung
dies brachte sind diese satelliten die
indien baute um die indische büros wird den
amerikanischen firmen zu verbinden was war etwas
woran niemand anderer als die branche gedacht
habe und durch all dieser effekt wurde eine
positive rückkopplung ein selbstverständlicher
kreislauf für die indische it industrie in gang
gebracht ja selbst die finanzkrise der neunziger
jahre diente dem interesse von ted india dann wäre
die indische regierung wie verrückt abwertet
und der rest der wirtschaft unter der starken
inflation liegt wurden die exportorientierten
softwarefirmen noch wettbewerbsfähiger und so
kam es dass im jahr 2000 die indische software
industrie bereits über 5 milliarden dollar schwer
war tja aber selbst diesen riesigen buben sollte
ein weiterer wendepunkt vollkommen in den schatten
stellen denn mit dem jahr 2000 kam etwas was
tech india weltweit noch viel wichtiger machte
das jahr 2000 problem diejenigen die sich dieses
video ansehen und über 30 jahre alt sind erinnern
sich vielleicht an diese geschichte hast du
dich noch an die sogenannten millennium bug
viele experten warnten damals vor dem ende der
welt wie wir sie kennen aber worum ging es dabei
eigentlich das 1 1 kriegen und bezeichneten jahr
2000 computerfehler als eine weltweite krise und
als eines der schwerwiegendsten und potenziell
verheerenden ereignisse denen dieses land je
begegnet ist also speicherplatz war früher in
den 60er und 70er jahren teuer daher benutzten
die programmierer einen kleinen kniff sie
speichert nur die letzten beiden ziffern
einer jahreszahl zum beispiel 60 von 1960 oder
10 für 1910 so konnte bei jeder datumsangabe
etwas speicherplatz gespart werden ja aber das
dicke ende kam dann später wenn viele dieser
programme die mit jahreszahlen größer 2020
umgehen konnten liefen viele jahrzehnte lang
bis in die 90er jahre und eben auch über das
jahr 2000 hinaus und dies konnte in der tat zu
schwerwiegenden fehlern oder abstürzen führen und
als das jahr 2009 rückte verwandelten die medien
dieses eher technische problem natürlich wie
so oft in eine irrationale angst und panik die
apokalypse oder zusammenbruch der zivilisation
wurden vorhergesagt und während einige medien
noch bis zum kritischen jahreswechsel 99 2000
besorgte berichte verbreitet hatten stellte sich
dann anfang 2000 heraus dass die vorsorglichen
massnahmen im großen ganzen ausreichend gewesen
waren das ende der welt fällt auch diesmal nicht
statt nichtsdestotrotz die mediale hysterie sagte
für einen wahren geldregen beiden software
firmen und die indischen war ganz vorne mit
dabei denn woher sonst sollte die welt auf einmal
so viele zusätzliche programmierer her bekommen
und so fühlten sich myriaden fleißiger
in der durch milliarden von codes fallen
die zeiten in denen der millennium bug beißt
zu indien war damals einfach zur rechten zeit
mit den rechten leuten zur stelle denn das was
es zu bieten hatte war weltweit einmalig jedes
jahr 100.000 neue internet absolventen das teilt
der indische programmierer lag nur bei einem
sechstel des niveaus und nasscom der lobbyverband
montag via schickte eine armee von vertrieblern
auf jede messe der welt von luxemburg bis ost
von new york bis zur see und erfolg war riesig
1998 machte der millennium bug 40 prozent der
einnahmen von texten die er aus der millennium
bug heißt indien damit sich als führender software
markt zu positionieren und im laufe des nächsten
jahrzehnts also den 2000er jahren festigte in
den diese position indem es das sourcing auch
auf high end bereiche ausweitete also forschung
und entwicklung als die architektur & process
integration globale unternehmen richteten in
den offshore zentren für strategieberatung und
end to end lösungen ein darüber hinaus war
das business process outsourcing ein riesen
rennen was das ist das ist die auslagerung
kompletter generische geschäftsbereiche alle
kundenkontakte oder die bearbeitung von
versicherungsansprüche und so schoss der
indische it sektor im vergangenen jahrzehnt über
zwei millionen neuer arbeitsplätze unter 10.000
neue technologie unternehmen so und heute ist
die indische it industrie 177 milliarden dollar
schwer ende gut alles gut möchte man meinen
aber moment mal denn an dieser stelle endet
unser schönes märchen von teck india denn jetzt
zeigen wir die dunkle seite der indischen macht
in den zwei länder in ein es gibt noch eine
weitere sache für die indien berühmt und
berüchtigt ist sein kassensystem denn indien ist
eine knallharte klassengesellschaft und das ist
alles andere als klasse und wenn du dir sagt dass
die neue moderne bunte und schillernde welt wäre
da ganz anders antwort der leistungsorientierung
der gleichheit und emanzipation dann wirst du
dich gewaltig das genaue gegenteil ist der fall
die indische industrie ist das beste beispiel
dafür wie in indien die schere zwischen arm und
reich immer weiter aufgeht denn worum handelt es
sich eigentlich bei dieser geschichte von tecan
die ja genau nun es geht um eine kleine insel
des wohlstands die von einem meer ist allens
umgeben ist ein reiches indien inmitten eines
armen indiens und was geht eigentlich in diesem
ganzen rest des landes ab nun erstaunlicherweise
haben weniger als zehn prozente ende ein
internet zugang wird indische programmierer
gleichzeitig die welt darüber im ländlichen
raum haben sogar nur drei prozent der menschen
zu hause einen internetanschluss sicherlich
ist es großartig in indien im it bereich zu
arbeiten als entwickler kann mit einem gehalt
von etwa 10.000 us dollar pro jahr loslegen und
karriere machen okay das klingt für westliche
verhältnisse nicht nach einem besonders hohen
einkommen aber in indien kann man das schon
sehr gut leben denn in einer stadt die bänke
law kostet eine wohnung zum beispiel weniger als
200 dollar im monat aber der zugang zu trennen
die ja erfordert ein hohes bildungsniveau gute
englischkenntnisse und eine menge soziales kapital
und das sind dinge welche für die meisten in der
immer unerreichbar sein werden ein programmierer
zu sein ist der ultimative indische traum
es gibt nicht nur darum in städten die enkel
oder mumbai einen guten job zu bekommen es
geht auch um die aussicht arbeit im ausland
japan ist auf der suche nach indischen text aber
werden diese anbeißen sie die das deutsche dieses
angebot lockt indiens it experten nicht an der
guardian im silicon valley sind 50 prozent ein
gastarbeiter mit dem berühmten radsport wie
visum in ähnlich sieht es offiziell aus wo
amazon und microsoft ihren hauptsitz haben
aber jetzt halt dich mal fest der lange arm
des indischen kastensystems reicht um die ganze
welt ja es herrscht sogar selbst in den zentren
der buchkultur befindet das unglaublich nur die
menschenrechtsorganisation e quality labs hat
im rahmen ausgiebiger studien herausgefunden dass
in der aus den untersten kasten in es unternehmen
und universitäten also unternehmen wie facebook
amazon oder microsoft systematisch diskriminiert
werden und ausgerechnet die tatsache dass es
in der it-branche der usa schon so viele in
der gibt wird der mitglieder der unteren kasten
zum fluch und du kannst mir glauben dass dies
die betroffenen kein zuckerschlecken ist
wenn hinter den abstrakten begriff der
diskriminierung stecken verbale und körperliche
angriffe erniedrigungen benachteiligung im
bildungssystem und bei beförderungen und sogar
sozialer exklusion diese geht sogar bis zur wahl
des sexual und lebenspartners das heißt in
der aus den höheren kasten lehnen es ab die
aus den niedrigeren zu denken die meisten
angehörigen der unteren kasten versuchen
daher ihre herkunft unter allen umständen
einzuhalten und leben auch in ihrer neuen
heimat in ständiger angst vor einem outing dennoch
ist es der traum der meisten in der einen dieser
jobs zu bekommen und in diesem ticket aus dem
mehrheits in die nacht in die ersten zu können
mein ticket nach draußen das indische dorf in
denen jede familie ein ingenieur hat der guardian
im dorf bartoli in nordindien beispielsweise
hat sich die ganze gemeinde zusammengeschlossen
sie stellt ressourcen und einrichtungen
bereitet damit kinder an einer der indischen
universitäten studieren können die eltern legen
alle ihre ersparnisse zusammen und nehmen darin
auf nur um damit die nachhilfe unterricht ihrer
kinder bezahlen zu können damit diese später die
aufnahmeprüfungen der begehrtesten bestehen können
im jahr 2017 wollen sollen sich studenten aus
diesem einen dort an der technischen universität
aufgenommen aber trotz all dieser anstrengungen
machten die unteren kasten nur neun prozent des
gesamten lehrpersonal an den hochschulen aus was
geschieht also in westindien warum west ist
nicht so stark wie tekken er nun die wahrheit
ist dass indien abgesehen von computern immer
noch ein zutiefst protektionistische land ist
und ein wahres paradies demokratie gemäss dem
esoc doing business index also dem ranking der
länder nach ihrer geschäfts freundlichkeit
rangiert indien irgendwo neben saudi arabien
oder decken keine möchtest du ein beispiel für
jede indischen zustände haben die selbst kafka
im traum nicht eingefallen wären tja da könnte
ich stunden erzählen aber nehmen wir nur mal das
englische was das system also bei uns kennen
wir ja zwei der steuersätze einen normalen
und ermäßigten satz für lebensmittel und so
weiter auch das ist manchmal schon verwirrt
aber für die bürokraten des subkontinents ist
das alles amateurhaftes gependelt in den indien
muss nicht nur jedes produkt eine eigene steuer
haben nein manchmal haben sogar verschiedene
modelle desselben produkts unterschiedliche
mehrwertsteuersätze in weiß was beispiel sogar
innerhalb des landes zwischen dem indischen
bundesstaaten gibt es toll und macht barrieren
sowie in europa vor noch 200 jahren wenn du mal
nach indien reist werden die eventuell überall
lange schlangen von lastwägen mit waren auffallen
das liegt daran dass hier von ihnen eine interne
zollkontrolle durchlaufen muss und dass unter
umständen gleich mehrfach während einer fahrt
durch das land hinzu kommt der außenhandel
deren computer zwar zollfrei sind belegt in
denen alle übrigen produkte von arzneimitteln bis
zur kleidung mit einigen der höchsten zoll setzte
der welt ja und die rechtsextreme regierung von
rameau die macht die dinge nicht einfacher ganz
im gegenteil indien plant zusätzliche zölle und
handelsbarrieren für 300 importierte produkte so
sind in den letzten zwei jahren zum beispiel die
us firmen sind und vollmar zu modis zielscheibe
geworden und genau wie im falle von ibm früher
möchte modi jetzt diesen unternehmen das leben
zur hölle machen das geht sogar so weit dass
ihre vollkommene verbannung aus dem e-commerce
auf den indischen markt diskutiert werden dem
confederation force india trading will ein
siebentägiges verbot für amazon wegen verstoßes
gegen die herkunftsland regel business today die
frage lautet nun also warum den ihnen die in
der regel für die software lässt sich nicht
einfach auf die übrige wirtschaft aus findet er
sich bei indiens wurden gar um eine blase die
weit klassen wird dann nämlich wenn die schere
zwischen teck india und miserabel india zu weit
auf geht es alles was ihr dazu einfällt wie immer
in die kommentare denn wir sind auf diese schon
hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe dass wir dieses
video gefallen und lag etwas gebracht hat was
ja die uns mit einem daumen hoch und unterstützen
uns in dem du ist mit seinen freunden heißt und
vergesst nicht dass wir jede woche neue videos
hochladen abonnieren sie unseren kanal und klicke
auf das klingeln um rechtzeitig benachrichtigt
zu werden was gut und bis zum nächsten mal